[Music]
so idle is coming back and supposedly
you're gonna be the first announcement
that you're gonna be a judge on the new
American Idol judge not lest ye be
judged
but they didn't say anything about
constructive criticism and I'm good at
that Katy Perry is on Tuesdays Ellen
DeGeneres Show
and she's playing coy about those
reports she's joining ABC's American
Idol as a judge so you're gonna be the
judge on American Idol what a fantastic
surprise ABC is expected to officially
announce the judges and host of the
revamped series soon et was with Ryan
Seacrest exactly a year ago he told us
this you were a little bit ambiguous
about the ending of Idol do you ever
foresee it coming back or I don't know I
felt like that was the thing to say
because it could and it's such a for me
it's such a great show such a part of my
life it could come back in some other
form somewhere else so Never Say Never
she's teased what form it would come
back in I don't know yet where if you
hosted I would love to host that show
again
[Music]